as the booster rollout continues at
record-breaking pace numbers of omricron
cases are also reaching new highs the
question now is whether christmas is
safe
so far no clear answer but the
government has refused to rule out
further restrictions before christmas
day
we keep the situation under review of
course we will assess the report the
recent report will be given by sage we
will challenge certain assumptions and
we'll come to a government decision
pressure is mounting on the government
after its scientific advisors published
advice saying tougher measures are
needed very soon to limit the impact of
omicron measures which could see the
return of a ban on meeting indoors
it comes as the british medical
association has warned 50 000 nhs staff
could be off sick with covid come
christmas day unless stronger
restrictions are brought in just started
off with a little bit of a sore throat
and sneezing this gp is isolating at
home after testing positive for covid
she's concerned about the future impact
on her patients as a team we've all
worked really
hard during the last uh 20 months to
make sure that we stay well and we stay
safe
and especially for our patients and
vulnerable as well um but we're all
worried we're worried about the numbers
going up we're worried about um staff
falling ill and not being able to
provide the sort of frontline service
that we have been so far across the
country more and more people are lining
up to get jabbed but will it be enough
to slow down the spread of kovid a major
incident has been declared in london
because of the number of omicron cases
authorities here in chelmsford are
prepared for things to get worse we're
keeping a very close eye on what's
happening in london we've got teams of
people across all of our systems in the
nhs
planning
should there be a surge in this locality
hence the reason why we're putting on
the extra capacity for vaccines and
urging everybody to get vaccinated as
soon as they can people here are heeding
the call my father-in-law is actually
quite poorly with it at the moment
we've lost a few people close to us so
it means even more to us to do what
we're supposed to do really i would
welcome more restrictions i think um
it's i think it's probably needed
hopefully uh christmas is all in good
shape and uh we stay ahead of it but
scientists warn staying ahead will take
more than vaccines
with cases of omicron rising
dramatically will we see the prime
minister impose more restrictions and
put his roadmap out of lockdown in
reverse and if so
when
charlotte lomas sky news